so hello everybody i am here with
Benedict Sheehan and Talia Maria Sheahan
they are a couple that I've been kind of
in my circles for the last several years
they're good friends altar with Andrew
Gould that you've seen on this channel
they Benedict is also participates in
the Orthodox Arsenal but mostly Benedict
is a composer of sacred music he is also
a conductor and he is the director of
music at st. econ's seminary and
monastery and his wife Talia Maria is a
vocalist and she also teaches music as
well but mostly they really work as a
team in all kinds of projects and in
this discussion we're going to look at a
particular project which really I find
very fascinating and which is the
artifact Institute
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world Oh Benedict and Charlie
Maria I will give you a chance to maybe
introduce a little bit introduce
yourselves a little bit I know that that
you are very involved in the community
there at Santa cons involved just in
music in the orthodoxy in general so
maybe you can tell us a little bit about
the things that you're working on that
you've accomplished and we can move into
move into the artifact Institute as well
yeah sure
do you want to start oh I'll start okay
yeah and be and whenever I speak to
anybody I haven't seen before I do I
like to explain that I do speak with a
step with us when a sister it's not your
imagination and I and I also explain to
people that I do it deliberately to get
attention it's it's been it's been a
long-standing tactic of mine and it
works beautifully so I'll continue to do
it know so yeah so as you said I'm a
composer and a conductor and I've I
started in in church as a teenager I
just started I just began to get
interested in the music of the Orthodox
Church my parents were converts to
Dorothy oxi
when I was 9 you wouldn't never have
guessed that I would become a church
musician I had no interest in Satan sake
of music at all I really didn't have a
lot of interest in church until I was
probably 14 when I when I when I when my
when my grandmother who was not where
they just sent me a recording of a
Russian male choir singing singing
Orthodox music and that recording
basically kind of changed the whole
trajectory about my life
and and from that point on I just became
interested in music and music of the
church but also just music in general
and that's kind of set me on the path
that I've remained on ever since so I do
all kinds of things it's not it's not
easy to make a croupier in America as an
Orthodox Church musician
that's the understatement yeah so I've
done all kinds of things but for the
last 10 years I've been as teens antique
guns and been really trying to create a
job and and and so 10 years later it's
really it's kind of the only job of its
kind in the country and I'm still trying
to bandit but we have we now have a
music staff I've got we've we've started
up a professional and Zombo under the
auspices the monastery called the st.
Egon choir which is the first pro choir
in under the auspices of an Orthodox
institution that's ever been been
created here in America and we've made
some recordings we just recorded or just
in 2019 we recorded my Divine Liturgy
which was a new piece that was
commissioned by the petrm Institute and
that'll be out this coming fall I've
started to work with a group on the west
coast called couldn't called cappella
Romana
I've been out there and number of times
to conduct them and they're gonna be
performing my new energy in November
with me conducting at least that's so
the plan well see if there's still
there's still such a thing as alive as
Live Arts come football but let's let's
pray that it continues I don't know I um
I recently
finally broke through into the world of
choral publishing and got published by
Oxford this year and and they recorded a
piece of mine and there hopefully
there's more to come on that front too
so I can't even keep track of it all but
that's okay one did it one day at a time
good problem yeah and one of the things
I forgot to mention is that you both of
you have seven daughters which is
amazing yeah right we have well it was
diapers to dating so now it's it's
college to preschool so like that's the
monolith forward you know it goes on it
so no tenors unfortunately well one of
our daughters that's the same time she's
great not me well I've seen some of the
things you've been putting on social
media some of the family choir stuff
it's really touching to see it's very
beautiful you know you're doing
different styles as well different
traditions and it's it's it's very
beautiful and touch it for those of us
like for myself who's not very musical
you know I like music I'm just not very
musical I I have that dream and and I
have this vision of you know the family
singing together it's very beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes usually not alone
yes it's a really powerful design I mean
that's honestly that's one of the things
that we found in our work which is you
know you can work you can work in in in
this sort of like you know the
technically kind of high you know high
proficiency levels in an art and and
that's one kind of way to be and then
you can work with beginners and that's
another kind of way to be and what we
found in in our being here at Santino is
that partly because of what the vision
of the abbot for the Sergius on the end
of the monastery is and then the mission
of the seminary to you know their
there's their kind of foam to two sides
two cents to different there's exactly
they're separate but but they um there's
such a strong there's such a strong
value for liturgy here that partly just
because it gets done every day which is
almost incomprehensible it's just such a
huge job it's an insanely huge job so
all the resources that get put into this
high-frequency reiteration of liturgy
mean that problems get they come up more
frequently and they have to be addressed
and solved more quickly so if I like to
use the metaphor that this is kind of
the fruit flies of the liturgical world
so we see the evolution of the species
as it were at a faster rate and you know
so so problems will the community that
only serves once a week even literally
take them seven times longer to to come
up with the problem that comes kinds of
problems that come up here right so you
know my end of this is that I'm a
vocalist and a music teacher and so we
kind of tag-team really nicely because I
help prepare the individual musicians to
be able to work with him and
and as he works with them then he brings
them to higher and higher levels so we
kind of have this cyclical process and
they have to go back to you yeah so it's
really interesting to see how that
combination of work you know just me
working with the singers in some
abstracted way of trying to get them to
sing better be better have better
musicianship skills wouldn't have an
application and just him working with
him on repertoire and trying to get the
services done it was kind of you
probably hit a plateau and I think a lot
of a lot of people who are trying to
trying to make beauty in the arts they
only have one or another of those things
and have to search for the other one on
their own and we just I guess
providentially just came like ready
bundled so another surgeon yes it's
definitely responsible for that support
I mean it takes a it takes somebody with
a vision to support artists in a way
that he supports us and the seminary too
so we're really lucky in that I mean all
great did not maybe not all but a lot of
great art statistical work in the of the
past has depended really on patronage
and on and and to a certain extent that
we we get to benefit from that
like we're providing a context you know
we have to we have to work for our daily
bread obviously but but um there there's
a sense and I think that's one of the
things really remarkable about the
leadership here is in at any cons is
there's a sense that that the work we're
trying to do is valuable that we are
we're given a context in which to
basically figure it out enter to enjoy
try to solve problems on trauma on our
own and to and to offer what we can draw
for new ideas to offer new creative work
in that context and I mean we're really
as you know as the years go by we really
really believe in in this idea of
context but you can't just produce art
or produce you know do you do anything
creative
in an in a kind of vacuum or best for
yourself I mean you mean there's a
certain element that you do it for
yourself because that's what you need to
do so if you're alone and you're an
artist that's what you that's what you
do because you need to make art to
survive but it's still important
like really believe that art is it's
about communicating communicating
breaking the other and so you do the art
because you need to but how much better
is it if there's a context in which you
can communicate and and in a context
where what you wear a will twice your
community K is both valued and and and
understood yeah um yeah that's one of
the things that I've let's say even
let's say there's this aspect of
communication but one of the aspects
that I've been trying to emphasize a lot
is the idea of participation you know
where we have a sense in our culture
that art is is a it's something that you
look at or something you listen to that
it really is a passive it passive act
whereas what I'm seeing with what you're
doing in terms of choir music in terms
of also this artifact Institute that
we'll talk about is trying to create a
laboratory that is not just a laboratory
for artists we're making things but the
community which is also going to be
receiving the fruits of this art right
so it's this symbiotic relationship
between what's not really a public and
the kind of you know modern way of
understanding public but is really those
who are benefiting who are participating
and for kind of collaborating with you
to create this this the symbiotic art
you know that's in the community like
you said that's in a that's being
communicated through people but also
with them as well oh yeah oh yeah I mean
I couldn't I couldn't agree more
we I mean the the the the the thing
about singing and singing to get to take
it together is I mean is that it's it's
really it's a really old idea dear
people
doing this for a very long time like
since the beginning of humanity like
like some of the oldest some of the the
oldest prehistoric artifacts there's the
word see we did that see what we did
there yeah are are actually musical
instruments there's a forty one thousand
year old bone flute um I can't the name
of it escapes me but it will come back
at some point but it's actually one of
the oldest artifacts that exists and
it's a flute like so if if we have that
it's not like some guy just had this
idea I'm going to make a bone into a
flute I mean it's it's got a wasted it's
got one place to change the pitch so if
we got that it means that it was an
older idea than man by far I mean it's a
thing that had to be yeah it had to be
generated over time over a long period
of time you know but but if we've got
nobody think about singing is that of
course to make music with your voice or
to make musical sound to make rhythmic
sounds is a thing that's a lot more
intuitive than it is then it would be to
like to carve an animal bone into a
flute so yeah that can't be the only
preservation is like isn't our biology
so everybody seems to love this so much
it's like in contexts where there's no
explicit instruction to say we sang like
it I don't know like it's soccer games
you know or in when people are drinking
or wooden people are fighting like what
is it about singing that makes it so
that that seems to be a reasonable thing
to do in such an intensely you know like
not terribly celebratory context maybe
necessarily but somehow deeply deeply so
a so we really believe that is something
that's really really deeply rooted in
mankind and and it's in that sense it's
a part of you just part of what it means
to be be to be a person yeah um you know
that's what people do people think so so
to speak about about your idea of art
that's participative sorry
there's no there's no more kind of
fundamental pretty part it's just a
stereo art and then when we sing
together um where does where is the song
I mean the song doesn't exist on the on
the sheet of music you know it doesn't
exist even in the recording it only
exists either in the experience of
hearing the song or in the act of
actually producing this you so in and of
itself it's already assumed that there's
two people there you know just super
inches I think one of the things that
really defined I I mean this is to my
understanding this is my own speculation
is that the real one of the reasons why
music is what defines human beings one
of the aspects which define us is
because it does have to do with patterns
it has to do with our capacity to to see
but also engage in patterns and so the
idea of music it's it's it really is a
pure pattern it's one of the purest
forms of patterns that you can find you
know it's almost mathematical in its
purity but then as you said singing
together it brings the pattern not only
as this kind of mathematical or you know
participation in opposites and in
variation and all of this but it's also
doing it in a way that's creating a
social pattern at the same time right so
it's it's absolutely together yeah right
yeah well I mean it's because it's a
pattern
but but art like visual arts are
patterns kind of in space what's so
interesting about music is that it's a
pattern in time it turns time into a
pattern and that way the liturgical year
the cycle of East's and fasts the you
know the the width of them of the days
of the week you know all of that is in
some sense it's a musical phenomenon
it's turning time into something
rhythmic yeah it is something is
something into something ordered
something patterned and therefore easy
infinitely it's both infinitely various
but also but also familiar and it kind
of roots itself in the memory and in the
experience so in that way I mean it's
music my dad used to say that that Mike
Mike my dad was not a musician my dad
was very kind of kind of figure and uh
but my dad used to point out that the
only arts that we that we know from
Scripture that that exists in the age to
come is music singing right because we
know the angels sing and then the song
at the end of time and you know all this
all the images in Revelation we don't
know that there's going to be a I can
nog Rafi we don't know that there's
going to be architects is that City
there is that whole city you know well
there's that it's truly it's an
architectural I don't need you I'll give
me that yes well it's a but but I do
think that there's some like this idea
of turning time into a pattern yeah is
really important now I think you're
right and I think it's interesting
because when you read the ancients and
they talk about things like the music of
the spheres or they talk about music
itself and you see this own idea that
music was part of the
you know the core curriculum of the of
the Ancients there really is a sense
that music is bigger than just even what
we understand his music today it really
is this this idea of the of the world as
being patterned a time being patterned
as the whole idea of participating in
the patterns you know was you the word
music was used to manifest that you know
and so but it is in a way the purest
form because also because it is
spiritual right it's it's non-physical
it's not like architecture or like I
cannot like images or like objects
making a share it is a it is a pure
pattern it's a pure pattern that you can
pick up you know like you were saying
where does it where is the song if I can
sing a song in the morning and then I
sing the same song at night you know
it's like I'm it's the same song but I
manifest you know I'm uh I'm resonating
it but the song is this really in this
spiritual pattern and so it is a way to
it is a way for us to connect to the
patterns of the world and to understand
also what it is that we mean when we
talk about spiritual things no and to
your point Benedict the idea that we see
the angels singing that we have this
image of the heavenly choir is also to
help us understand that there is a
relationship even with principality with
angels and with this idea of singing
that there that they are manifesting the
the pattern back up to God they're kind
of you know they're glorifying God by
using these patterns and they're also
manifesting it to us as we kind of hear
this glorious singing of that that is
going up to God that's that's beautiful
one of the most spectacular things that
I enjoy intensely is is the although I
don't ever feel really entirely capable
of dealing with it um is the the
closeness of of the soul in the singer
and I think I tell until our students
but here there's no mistake that the
church says that we are to sing in our
worship if that is not accidental it's
not because we didn't have the resources
to have instruments or something like
that that's uh huh so
the singing not because it's not because
it's so the the the experience of trying
to you know expressing the ideal of a
certain kind of sounds in singing it's
entirely individualized the ideal of a
singer's voice is totally peculiar to
that individual because what makes up
that voice is totally you know the
unique shapes and sizes of the various
pieces of tissue and so yeah well let
alone there's their psychology so it's
just the act of trying to find the ideal
voice for every individual is it a
personal dream and when you then try and
actually use those tools to their most
efficient and most effective and most
beautiful end what you invariably come
up against are are are the you know
basically your rooms and so I joke that
I'm so sorry all my students but your
voice lesson is a therapy session and
it's even worse than therapy because in
therapy you can be like yeah the next
time I come up against this difficulty I
am going to behave this way that's how I
want to be that's the ideal I'm gonna
shoot for well in a voice lesson there
is no the next time is right that second
and if you don't do it you'll be able to
tell that you didn't do it and you will
be disappointed and you will have to try
the immediate second actors dude yet to
do it again it's like the most real time
were self like you know Soulcraft hmm
that I have found in in frankly any of
my teaching and then when you get a
bunch of people trying to do that and
then frankly that process sounds a heck
of a lot like repentance like active
repent you get a bunch of people
individuals trying to do that who come
together to then try and do that at the
same time towards the same end
that's why seeing it together with
people it's transcendent hmm that's
that's exceptional and so you know part
of our work here has been to say and and
to be completely honest a lot of people
who feel um feel drawn to the church
don't
Sara Lee feel that way because they feel
like they're good you know I'm fine
uncomfortable with who I am this is
great they they want more for themselves
and sometimes that wanting more is it is
a once is a desire to share with other
people and then you get a pastoral
impulse well a lot of those folks don't
tend to have the let's just be blunt the
requisite ego to be able to actually use
their bodies confidently and and that's
why kind of you know the performer is is
this almost a psychological type you
have to have a huge amount of actual
psychological and physical confidence to
be able to make a good sound and so the
process of trying to get people who are
already somewhat inclined towards self
criticism or somewhat inclined towards
putting themselves definitely second in
you know it in order to care for others
or feel like what they're being told by
by the two churches they have too bad
too or they have to basically like that
the idea that there for us to repent and
have humility it means that we have to
tell ourselves that were bad mm-hmm that
is we I just this is this is like these
are actual impediments to doing the job
um and you know it's stuff like this
that you wind up coming up against when
you have to sing together every day four
hours a day and you have to sing better
so what we found in our work here and
you know I think it's possible that
educational institutions and even you
know educational institutions that are
founded in a church community which
there ought to be more they they could
come up against these these issues and
try and figure out how to solve them
just as we have but we have this
advantage of the frequency so the other
thing is like when you sing you you you
know why you can't pretend that you're
all together there's no I mean like
there's a certain tact
sorry there's a certain way in which you
do have to pretend when you
because he and if you don't feel like
the you know the the thing that that
you're singing about you still have to
act like you do but but in terms of the
active actually singing well there's no
way to pretend that you're single so
it's it's like so but but like we have
this thing in like in the church I think
we're we're like like when we can eat
certain extent we can pretend to be
really spiritual and and and and we can
can do all kinds of other things that
aren't really spiritual at all but we
think that they are it looks like they
are and so we can get by and like we can
all be really religious Wow but then
when we try to sing it's like a note not
it's not happening pretending they're
yeah right so that's a great thing too
it's like if we all if we all worked a
little bit more to keep together I'm
trying to single see well then then we
might find that we can solve some of our
other problems too interesting so we we
kind of got artifact from this process
of continually coming how do people come
to us and say please help me please
please help me and maybe tell us what
tell us what artifact we don't give us a
sense of what it is because cuz I I know
what it is but I want people to get a
sense of what it is because it's a it's
a very fascinating mission it's one
which just makes so much sense when I
saw it so so please tell us what it is
and then and then we can put in there
the story a little bit of how it came
about
absolutely yeah well okay so the
artifact Institute is a collective what
we're Connie is is a collective of a
culture appropriators in in in very
basic terms it's a company that we found
it in in the past six months no time
yeah I don't know especially now who
knows what dated oh gosh what's every
day is this the same you talk about them
rhythmic the rhythmic ordering of time
but there is no written
so so we we kind of started with the
idea and this is evolved out of our
discussions with our friend and
colleague Nick guitar and also uh to
some extent but better on with with with
with Bishop Alexis who is he lives it's
in 2d guns he's an elected bishop and
yeah um to kind of figure out a way to
solve what we think of as the problem
let's say the problem of context we're
religious yes um but we we all kind of
understand that nobody can be religious
all the time or you know or there has to
be you know they're there as an Evan
full blow to life there's an ebb and
flow to the week there's an Evan flow to
your own lifetime and we go to church
but but it's like what do you do with
the rest of your time or you know so it
doesn't mean Oh should my should the
rest of my week start to look like
Church is it not the idea is like well
people have tried that we've read that
it's not it's not really the answer and
I don't think it's just animal for most
people or maybe for anybody
interestingly that's not what the life
of the monastics here necessarily I
don't think that's what even a wife in a
monastery maybe some people can sustain
that but so it's like well what do you
do with the rest of your time and we're
also starting with this question if like
we have a church but where is the church
what's around it where where did what's
the context of the church and so one of
the things we came to realize is that a
church exists in a culture it's not just
a thing that stands on its own it's it's
a you know it's in the churches in a
town that the town is in a region the
region is in a country but but it's like
so
what is it that sustains the life of the
church well it's it's a culture um and
and in the past that the whole idea of
culture kind of evolved and a lot of
what we think of as culture is just the
way either people have grown and adapted
and evolved to live to get together to
work together to eat each other in great
part just so they don't die um it's not
some lofty ideal right so we so we form
a town we form a tribe we form a village
so we so we can eat so we can be safe so
we can raise our children in our tribe
our species if you know I don't anybody
then it's a thing like that but but you
know so that it can continue to continue
um we now in our time have this really
interesting problem problem yeah and I
get again AIDS it's all precarious a
certain extent but but we've we have
we've managed to solve a lot of the kind
of practical problems of humanity and we
are continuing to solve them I mean
that's what we're doing right now I mean
infectious disease was just a part which
is too part of life for all of our for
all the time you know and the idea that
it would just wipe out a quarter of the
third or half the population was just
understood like that could occur what
what sweatsuit really interesting is
that we have a lot of tools and a lot of
systems and mechanisms to actually like
for us if they like that's not the norm
that's not what is going to occur or a
little at least we're trying to make it
be that and I think to a great extent
where we're we're being able to just
accept you see but what's interesting is
that's a new thing like humanity's never
really cool cool pull this off before
and
and so and I just I use that as an
example of the ways in which like most
of us know most of humanity most of the
time has enough to eat most of us have a
place to live most of us have you know
in cents a week we're we've managed to
create a remarkably secure Danville
society all over the world and we're you
know it's still a work in progress
obviously but but compared to basically
every other time it's pretty it's pretty
miraculous um so we know since like we
don't have to have a village or a tribe
in order to survive I from day to day
that's a remarkable thing but that's
introduced a new problem which is that
we now because so many of our needs are
provided for we don't know what we're
doing with our lives we don't know where
we belong we don't know we don't have to
connect with other people in order to
eat in order to not be destroyed by a by
a band of marauders so you know but yeah
so but yet were then we don't have to
connect with you people so we don't
connect with you people we don't do
things with other people we don't eat to
get together we don't sing to get it's
okay it's okay together we don't
celebrate together we don't really work
to keep take you take you can take
gather and right now in the midst of
warranting that's more true than it ever
has been um but so but we find that as a
result of that we're like really missing
some key things what kind of dying
inside and so what we think of is that
the patent past the phenomenon of
culture kind of created itself out of
necessity um but now we actually have to
create culture still out of necessity
but but a different a different kind we
needed to do it in order to know who we
are in order to know where we
in order to know what the purpose of our
life is in order to you know to connect
with others just you know if it's
different for our stoles to survive um
so that's part that's kind of the big
picture idea of like well so if we're
going to create these things we're gonna
like deliberately create culture rather
than it just being able to a curb on its
own how would that be done well you know
to a certain extent initiative scale too
right so what we also have in this time
of rather extraordinary you know
practical resources is insanely high
quality entertainment and I don't mean
that like just you know really really
produce stuff is amazing I mean that the
actual technical level of your average
piano students is considerably higher
even just in this past I don't know 40
50 years yeah then then it previously
was and you know recordings we have of
really you know exceptional ensembles
from the early 20th century they're kind
of like okay it's it's powerful its
emotive it's really beautiful now we but
technically it's like a little black
yeah I mean I think musicians are better
now on the average so they were right so
but the funny thing is that we have this
sense of all of this culture creating
being the responsibility of a
specialized class and and that being a
responsibility of a specialized class
has given the success this exceptional
entertainment but we didn't realize what
we were trading for that sort of
exceptional resource we didn't realize
that it was actually sort of
psychologically and spiritually
necessary for us to be working at this
ourselves not in order to kind of like
take down the ideal but we all were
supposed to be working choices not to be
on them no yeah but it's so it's so we
can know how to spend our time yeah but
it's it's it's shocking because in
Quebec you know we had a very
traditional culture not very long ago
and you know my grandparents you know in
their generation there they would still
you know take the table out of the
living room
get the local fiddle guy to come in and
you know call the dance and it was just
a normal part of of life you know that
you would do during the holidays you to
do for special occasions and that is
gone right so now you get a DJ to come
and play recorded music you know you you
dance but you don't dance together you
everybody dances individually so all the
manifestations of culture are showing us
that the problem that you talked about
which is in our in our moment of
self-sufficiency also in our moment of
our desire to move away from meaning and
move towards you know just this kind of
material wealth we've lost something
we've lost this togetherness yeah so so
in that circumstance you were going to
admitting that that is an ideal that you
like like it pulls at your heart somehow
if you are gonna try and reproduce that
that what what is the first question
that would come to you if I was gonna
try to reproduce that I would have I
would be completely lost in every manner
like I would be lost in exactly like how
to do exactly how can I do that
you know and I mean like I don't just
mean technically I mean like how to do
it in terms of even one getting people
to want it like even that is already the
first beginning and then getting myself
to want it deeply I can want it
intellectually but to put the effort
into like diet whoa that's a whole other
world so so sorry yeah to me it's like
it feels like that world is completely
lost so the easiest way to navigate
those treacherous waters is with a guide
and that is what our collective is we
because a we're pedagogues so not only
are we working in a specialized sort of
like you know we work in the
professional world and that really that
we could devote all our time and energy
to that and we would still be struggling
and there's no question about that
there's no end how good you can get see
but then it's kind of like you know the
the which is not to say I think we're
prophets but there's a certain job that
a prophet has in a community it's like
go find
some go have some revelation go have
some exalted experience and then you
better go back to your community and be
able to communicate that experience
right because how the heck else is
everybody gonna know what they're
supposed to be working towards and you
need to demonstrate it you need to model
it you need to explain it with language
and so we're trying to assemble a desert
extends we have to do task analysis on
ourselves we have to simplify how do we
do that and then we're trying to
assemble the technique that's required
in the team that it exactly well the
team to communicate that to be able to
guide people in this process of being
able to just work just have one
experience just have one experience of
this stuff you're lacking and you don't
have to change your life just do it once
and then maybe do it again right and so
what we've worked towards creating our
arc it's kind of a couple tiers of
activity one there's the educational
tier where we really assembly kind of
break down what what is is necessary for
the taking the first steps in any of
these we call them elements and then
being able to impart that now whether
that's one-on-one instruction or or
creative in a social context in which
the technique can have life and you know
um what you said about how to get
yourself to want to do it and how to get
other people to want to do it we all
know the awkwardness of a party where
you're really not sure why you're there
so it's like well I guess let's just
drink because that will know me the
question of what were you can do right
[Laughter]
you know it's like we think like people
drink too much at a party but I mean
that can be fun too but you know people
drink too much of parties because
they're partying too much but actually
we contend that they do it because
they're not partying not because they're
using alcohol to do all kinds of other
things that like but actually like like
thinking that there were listening to a
story or doing doing a contra dance or
playing an instrument or playing game or
you know even sitting on the edge the
party is important
in a room that's well decorated you know
carefully fire and you know again like
so we were using like a single thing to
do the job of all those other things so
I saw oranges is um the first big event
that we hosted was in Louisville and it
was in in January and it was over the
Feast of of Kemalists of entry of the
Lord into the temple and we mean meaning
I the one of the really extraordinary
insights that our our friend fish of
Alexis brought to the process of coming
up with with this was his experience of
being on Mount Athos and he was a monk
on lonely mountain for a little over a
decade and he explained you know how do
you get people who come from different
different cultures different countries
speak different languages to suddenly
live in an immersive way together and
have that kind of cohesion that you
really need in order to survive that
environment and he said there were three
aspects of life there and that was the
common worship and that was what
everything was founded on and then out
of that flowed the common work and then
from that and not least of the three was
the common feast and so we took that
formula and Bishop Alexis said his
experience was that was present at every
level of his monastic life and we took
that formula and we we thought okay
could we do this over a limited period
of time in a pedagogical way but also a
way that feels complete in you know a
remote location and so partly because of
the extraordinary sort of resources of
that community st. Michael's st. Michael
the Archangel into Jochen Church in
Louisville and partly because of the
assembly of people instructors and
students that came together there be
almost 200 people that you know we're
part of the the weekends program first
yeah
really it surprised almost all of us
with both its intensity and its advocacy
really so so the good news is that yeah
we can practice this we can get better
which is really encouraging you know
yeah I mean we do a number of things
under the artifact brand we as a team go
and do to do Church music workshops in
various parishes we've also started to
publish we created a song book of 12
essential folk songs that we think are
good for kind of a home gathering for a
party or songs you can sing with you or
with your friends or your cute kids and
we're gonna do more with that um we're
probably gonna make a recording to
promote that I think you know people
would like to learn from from recordings
and that's really for as those of us who
really can't read music when I say to
you
okay I feel like I can actually engage
with this now because the prints I was
like okay this is not for me that's
that's an entry point into the song but
there's a lot of other place to go and
by far the more the more common way to
learn a song for all of human history
was advised by ear so so yeah so we're
gonna help we're gonna try to work on
that we're gonna do consulting work
where we go into a community we speak
with them I work with them and we talk
about some things they can do and we
will even put on put on some kind of an
event or else except coach them in that
but we also want to they're there
they're there to be some really like
some magnet events where a lot of people
can come from from all over and that's
what we started
Louisville and the plan is to do it
again in 2021 where we can bring a
bottle upp together we and at that event
we well you should talk about the kind
of the
today I think that's a good way yeah
yeah that common common worship come and
work come and feast thing you know that
can happen over a long on multiple
scales so the we structured it so that
every day began with worship of me we
sang in small chunks the Karthus glory
got for all things which is kind of an
exceptional piece especially for the
board what's going on right now and you
know remarkable that it was composed by
someone who was it really is a very it's
very powerful for the modern it's a
masterpiece I think yeah and it's
actually I actually believe it's in a
three-act structure that mirrors the
cathartic journey of the heat yeah I
actually contend that the compass is
alright write it up Benedict said on our
symbolic girl ugh there go ahead yes um
we started with that in the morning and
part of the community is what's wrong
about it to a certain sense is
architecture so they have some really
amazing spaces that do what spaces are
supposed to do they tell you what you
are supposed to do in that who you are
and where you belong and I've heard you
say that before Jonathan like it's like
this the most significant art be in a
sort of sleeper way because we don't
know what to do with we're in a space
that's telling us to do one thing but
you know do a different thing
so so we were in a beautiful space that
really showed us that what we were
supposed to do you know be be still and
pray and that's why we started our day
and then the rest of the honorees the
work hours then we went to even went to
breakfast and then we did a group a
group singing a group alright so we did
the morning the morning singing and that
had yeah it was awesome
partly because what our goal I mean I've
heard only good things about that event
I've heard just amazing people just
really excited about it and I myself
feeling very lonely and like you know
peace and sanity we need to do so don't
worry don't worry
yeah no that but the the morning sing
was interesting because one of the one
of the weird things is that if you want
to have a celebration where something is
some corporate activity happens that
celebration can't be a new thing there
has to be some memory that that that
celebration is founded on that's the
kind of like oh we do this so we had to
teach the people there that these were
songs they sang so that when it came
time for the party they could be like oh
we should sing our songs but it took
several days of right of imparting that
and and holding their hands through that
process for them to then think okay
these are our songs and then that's
singing of them at the party which was
the final kind of you know capstone
experience not not remotely the high
point it was just another of the many
high points kind of it felt natural and
that was that was kind of an interesting
process pedagogical process for us
because because just like you said you
wouldn't know how to do a thing that you
didn't do hmm
if you don't do a thing then how do you
start doing a thing that's a barrier
that I think so many people come up
against when they try to make they want
to make their lives more beautiful but
that analogous memory thing like oh it's
gotta be like another
my Grimm my grandparents knew how to do
this but I don't and none of my friends
do and none of my family does so what do
we do so in a sense it has to be taught
um again or anew I don't know about
again as we taught a new things for us
and for our time and it seems like the
way you're doing it in the sense that
you're building up and you're actually
creating the experience of of learning
and then rejoicing in the thing you've
learned it seems like it's a nice little
microcosm of of how it can work on a
bigger scale you know because like I
said because it's lost we can't it's
harder for us to access the bigger scale
one so building these small scale ones
you know can can let's say layer up and
hopefully create bigger ones I think
it's a great it was super super exciting
to see it work so well it worked better
than we actually thought it was gonna
work which and so then after the morning
saying we would all dispersed to the
various disciplines that we were working
and so there was there was true painting
fir for confer conductors there was a
there was there was a program for
singers there was a program for writers
and storytellers and that's about as far
as we were able to do but to go with
this first one but we'd like to do more
and then we would come back together at
some point in the day direction of the
choir rehearsals and we were preparing
for a concert and then for four versus
service on Sunday morning for the Feast
of the meeting of the Lord and then the
concert was actually a narrative program
or nibble winning because our thought he
worked together with with date with the
other writers in the workshop to prepare
a narrative of the life of st. Simeon
mm-hmm more or less made up based on
some of the things we have from older
documents and then and then we
interspersed it with music sung by fire
which was made up of a bunch of
different piece of people the big car
was actually about to have an EP with
people and then there was a smaller
chamber group which was about 30 and
then there were 13 pros who were kind of
the core and then that each of them sang
a different thing and
and the whole thing had a narrative and
the argument what Nikki do Nikolas
noticed was that there was a symbol yeah
there was symbolic structure of the
hero's journey in the sequence of
vespers okay and so the actual service
of vespers could be melded with the
story that he wrote about st. simeon and
had the the sequence of hymnography in
it actually followed the arc of his life
and that was an exceptional experience
because real are our feeling was like
okay yeah we're gonna do a thing it's
best for is there's all these words but
we wanted to try and reawaken and choose
URI enchant Vespers and we had to find
the symbolic language in the service in
order to really do that and bring it
into a narrative and it was really
powerful it was really amazing it began
with the procession where people rolling
candles and singing and there was
incense and dance and the whole church
was dark and then we persist up to the
front and we lit everybody candles and
the narrator begins and then all the
lights come on when the fire began to
sing - sing Rachmaninoff and it was it
was pretty awesome
I mean it's for the epic so we did that
I think that when venom and then on the
next day we had we we had the liturgy
and the whole choir sang for the liturgy
and the student conductors who they also
helped to conduct in the liturgy and
then and the end of it all we had the
big feast and we we worked all through
the day to prepare the sort of base to
go in full formal forage for reader II
we brought in we were ironing the
tablecloths and putting out the candles
and setting up plates all under the
expert instruction of an hour
conviviality instructor Amanda Jacobs
who is a designer interior decorator and
designer
and who liked that task analysis thing
well you know these fancy things this
China have in my cabinet that's not for
me to use I wouldn't even know how to
use it so part of her job and everybody
participated in this partly because
we're trying time to tell people is that
this is this is you know this is amazing
I approach it's such a great idea to
have people prepare the feast at the
themselves you know and like iron the
the tablecloth put out the you know put
out the the decorate the tables do all
that so that it feels like this is our
fee this is not stop something's gonna
go into a hotel lobby like a hotel
greeting room and we just sit at the
table and that's it it's like this is
something intense you have to have all
three elements common worship so we all
can get to get the key together in some
way express what what is our ideal what
do we believe in what are we aiming at
and then then go port city became
continue drinking together and we all
sweat and you know so we know we do so
disappointing but but but but also the
bonds that you create when you work to
get together are very strong you know
people when we will work to keep it
together we meet a people in a much
deeper way than if we're just having a
chat or you know so we we work together
we know somebody has to also hold the
ladder while the other person that puts
up the candles that we hung from the
ceiling and you get your hands dirty and
you you know like there's a there's a
lot of bonds that you form as a
community when you when you do it when
you do tasks to get to get together and
really you know we're in a specific and
clear way and then we do all that and
then we all go back and we and we get
and and we put our nice party clothes on
and we come back to get together and the
room is lit with candles and there's the
bay
playing and there's champagne and
everybody's just like you know just like
just you know the the kind of the
reaction when people walked into the
room was just the kind of gasp like this
is so beautiful it's like it's like I
didn't realize that I deserved to be
treated like this or to treat myself
like that's a powerful that's a powerful
thing and then so we all sit down do we
know so we print print pray people gave
toasts people told stories people read
palms we sang songs we actually did
contra dancing they did Arabic Bogdan
dancing it was pretty spectacular and so
we were there for like four hours and
native-like like he didn't want ya you
didn't know how much time and time time
passed differently yeah but it would
have been it wouldn't have had that
transcendent values we hadn't all been
working towards an ideal that we shared
that we articulated together and and
that you know we all agreed upon sort of
implicitly and then shared and and
that's the context that a church comes
from I mean that that's what creates a
church and and so we we see left over in
society we see the churches with the
Foundation's underneath them eroding out
from them so what we're trying to say to
people is that okay so maybe you don't
live in a village anymore but those
things that people did um in that were
expressions of how their interaction on
a sort of micro level on we're it
important we can still do that we have
to modify our technique and we have to
have conversations with experts and with
artists and the culture creators and
with you know thinkers about how we
modify it because the each new age the
the technique changes because the tools
change in the context stage but there
are these sort of fundamental needs that
we need to address and at working
together we'll come up with a way more
you know authentic expression and it's
just we let some elite class do this for
us what do they know about us but how
can they act
we meet our peculiar needs you know
Hollywood can't produce all the stories
we have to tell some of our own right
exactly yeah yeah exactly and then and I
like I always say the story that
Hollywood they they tell us the stories
they're not our stories we don't
participate in them we don't feel like
they are that they connect to us in the
way that my story you know or hearing
the story of a friend you know all of
these stories are stories that you
engage with that you that you can pray
for the other person that you you have
this real interact and it's a it's a
real interlocking of stories you know
and there's nothing wrong with
entertainment versions or the you know I
love this story we need to not be
fighting with the other that's yeah yeah
greed
right because like you need like it's
like in this whole debate or now about
like how do we do because a lot of us
couldn't go to church for Easter and you
know we had the option to sit and watch
a whole 5 stream of church but in my
mind it's like it's like church you know
I like even being in church it's already
in some sense it's a virtual reality
because because of the whole the whole
like all the liturgical stuff we do is
always encoded symbols and these and
these stylized representations of things
which are all incense to create this
this this idea of the kingdom of God and
so that's already in my mind it's
already VR um you know and and and when
it's really well done it's really
powerful when it's not well done it's
not as great but um but but like if I
was like I couldn't wrap my mind around
then watching a virtual version of that
it's it was too far removed news to me
from reality and so so we were more so
our idea was to
to actually to create an order that
revolves around a meal and and and and
and prayers at the me all around we kind
of made a ritual of putting on the
clothes that you would have prayed over
Easter we visualize decorating at the
table and and and the bringing out of
the food and certain prayers to go with
certain parts of them you know and then
you know it's to make basically that's
what we can do on our own we can make
these to deal a bigger and more
meaningful experience and so that's what
we did we actually created an order of
that together with visuals of Lexus and
one of the priests monks at st. Akon's
and when we put in and we and then we
and then we and then we made that
available to to to people everywhere and
it actually got approved by the by this
by the Synod a bishops actually since
they actually that's amazing I'm angry
and and they were thing confused in
Australia and in South Africa and in
Germany and in the UK and all over
Canada so this is the sense of like we
we can because already was like let's
see why wouldn't worship and Easter look
like if it grew out of our own
experience yeah so so that's what was so
really it I think it work so we did that
because I feel like it's really
important that we not just do church
because that's what we because that's
what we do and I it's like like church
the worship of the church is a wonderful
and beautiful thing but it didn't just
come from nowhere it didn't just it
didn't just get dropped out of the sky
even if somebody able to believe that it
really didn't you know it's it involves
out of culture
elves out people of people being
together and having relationships and
then trying to find God and to know God
and to love God um that's where worship
football from you know but but if we
don't take part in that if we don't have
a sense of of that evolution if we don't
have a sense of where it fits into the
into the rest of our lives I really
worry it becomes just something that's
totally imaginary song is totally
totally artificial um or at least just
totally detached yeah though our sense
is so you know we have to kind of
reconnect those things well I think it's
a I'm really excited to see we're going
to this I really I all the things I've
seen have been beautiful I think that
that you've thought out the method and
also to kind of take people by the hand
and just kind of guide them through and
so and I think it's a it's really a
testimony to your to your own family to
your own community that you have the
strength at this time and kind of the
the resources to bring this together and
so I want to encourage everybody to to
go I'll be posting the links in the
description artifact you'll see also the
the downloads that they have and the
different resources that that they're
putting together hopefully when all of
this chaos of virus it goes away they'll
also be event and I will definitely be
going at at the next event because I'm
really excited
also I this project well you well it's I
mean it needs you we need you well thank
you because I feel like I need exactly
what you're doing so I I just I it's
just it's also really exciting for for
for me to see because we kind of started
having small collaborations who Orthodox
art journal and you know different
people work on different things and it's
just exciting to see us like with
Nicholas Kotar and yourselves and myself
and Andrew and all these different
people that we're on the same track we
all have our different little version of
it we all have
different vision but we you kind of
understand the problem in similar ways
and so it's great to feel like we're
even if we're not together physically
that we're we're a team in a certain way
that we're kind of working in the same
in the same direction so it's that's
exciting
exactly well I think that's I think at
least my my i I'm optimistic that that's
a sign that it's from is something from
God mmm that that that were we're all
being coordinated it that we're all
being coordinated in some ways like in
ways that we can't see or even
understand but it's like oh wow we're
all doing the same thing how did that
how did that come about you know I think
that's pretty neat and hop on the same
train alright guys so I'm gonna we're
gonna keep an eye on all of this and
hopefully in in a year or whatever we
can have another discussion and track
how everything has been going so I'm
looking forward to that as well awesome
look forward to it thanks so much thank
you talking to me I really liked it
thanks